2021 ist ein superwahljahr
bundestagswahl sechs landtagswahlen
schon in zwei wochen wählen rheinland
pfalz und baden württemberg nur und das
ist das besondere findet wahlkampf
diesmal hauptsächlich im internet statt
wegen sie wissen schon
die bundestagswahl im september wird die
teuerste aller zeiten
107 millionen euro kosten allerdings vor
allem gegen porto
stichwort mehr briefwähler was auffällt
in diesem jahr ist logischerweise der
klassische straßenwahlkampf also
politiker bei uns schon noch ihre stände
auf aber dann müssen sie sich
offensichtlich schnell verstecken
derzeit bauen sie nun regelmäßig ihr
sogenanntes kontaktloses zu hörmobil auf
um sich dann in mehr als corona konforme
ferne zu begeben
am kontaktlosen zu hörmobil kann jeder
der möchte den beiden eine postkarte
schreiben wo seid ihr faulen verbessere
fragezeichen
schreiben sie uns eine postkarte die
whatsapp nachricht der spd zu recht
zurecht wenn der ganze digitale
wahlkampf geht ja an den weniger
internet affinen menschen vorbei
deswegen werden in diesem jahr
zusätzlich besonders viele flyer in
briefkästen gequetscht und mal ganz
ehrlich wenn sie mal heißt ja der
politische diskurs im wahlkampf so oft
sind wir früher auch nicht durch die
stadt gegangen haben gesagt ja der cdu
stand da lasse ich mich noch mal
gepflegt voll aber allerdings für die
umwelt ist es ganz gut dass der
straßenwahlkampf mehr oder weniger
ausfälle mit dem ganzen team fdp an
diesen ständen verschenkt wird
das wissen viele nicht aber die berühmte
riesen müll insel im pazifik die besteht
zu einem drittel nur aus weggeschmissen
fdp kugelschreiber ist dieses jahr
erleben wir also den digital ssten
wahlkampf aller zeiten
die grünen zum beispiel haben ihre
follower zahl bei instagram seit 2017 um
mehr als 500 prozent gesteigert sind
jetzt sechs quatsch die afg freut sich
weil der algorithmus bei facebook
reißerische und polarisierende inhalte
bevorzugt während die spd ihren
spitzenkandidaten olaf scholz
tatsächlich schon auf digitale wahlkampf
tour geschickt hat und wie man neulich
beim politischen aschermittwoch gesehen
hat
das ist voll sein ding und darum müssen
wir über zukunftsvisionen sprechen die
wir anpacken müssen und wir müssen über
das was getan werden muss reden damit
wir den zug nicht verpassen nicht auf
dem falschen gleich landen sondern den
richtern und richtet den richtigen
richtige gleis nehmen und den richtigen
weg einschlagen
achtung an gleis 7 ist ein rhetorisches
zugunglück passiert vorsicht an gleich
sieben ja meine die eisenbahn als
metapher für zukunftsthemen genauso
spricht man die 2,8 millionen erstwähler
bei der bundestagswahl an
aber das tolle am internet ist selbst
ein scholz kannst du dir ja cool
hinfälligen wenn du willst was weiß ich
der scholzomat als hipster barista
natürlich mit men bahn oder noch besser
olaf scholz insta story power yoga mit
kathi hummels auf bali warum nicht die
älteren wir älteren werden uns daran
gewöhnen müssen es ist halt eine neue
art wahlkampf und es hat ja tatsächlich
auch vorteile
solche szenen fallen beispielsweise aus
irgendwelche idioten die eier werfen für
ein politisches statement halten wie
hier in der legendären szene wo kohl
diesen mythen des nassen durch die
aussies gepflügt ist im digitalen
wahlkampf eierwerfen macht überhaupt
keinen spaß macht doch keinen sinn sogar
tik tok wird neuerdings im wahlkampf
eingesetzt
es ist eigentlich eher so eine art
kinder medium teenager medium aber du
kommst wohl nicht mehr daran vorbei
vorteil man erreicht die ganz jung und
kann komplexe sachverhalte kurz auf den
punkt bringen ideal also für unter
komplexe politiker wie robbie schlund
von der afd schöner wintertag morgen da
sollen wir noch jemand was von
klimawandel und wieder einmal erlebt ein
half dem mann sein intellektuelles
stalingrad
dabei kann tik tok so viel mehr so viel
mehr viele politiker lassen sich jetzt
sogar speziell für tic toc coachen
katja gartz ist deutschlands erste tik
tok trainerin für politiker heute werden
eine grüne aus thüringen und ein spd
mann aus nrw fit gemacht fürs neue junge
medium also und von den grünen ist er
wichtig eingeschlafen weil das so
unfassbar lang von der ersten sekunde an
enthalten sonst fahren die kleinen
gehirne sofort wieder runter
zumal markus blume csu leute ich bin
neugierig und ich habe gehört es geht
hier vor einem guten reise deswegen beim
erstes video gleich mit dem süßen
kleinen welpen aber weiter acht sekunden
bis er ins bild so sekunden schaue ich
mir diese bauspar presse mit
kassengestell an folgende challenge 13
bis 24 jährige begeistern aber ohne euch
anzubiedern okay es darf nie krimi
werden es schon mal so richtig in
schwung zu bringen
[Musik]
okay geben diesmal anders an was ist der
tecdoc goldstandard lernen wir von den
westen
hier denke dass streifenhörnchen über 17
millionen viewer und noch - und genoss
wahnsinn
[Gelächter]
katerna gerz wird klar aus diesen
flippen werden niemals tik tok
sie beschließt die volle kursgebühr von
3000 euro zu kassieren und lässt die
beiden einfach eine stunde lang worden
so aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and cut
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich